I had a very similar challenge when we
started the Conan show you know that was
I left Saturday Night Live he was he was
the first headwriter of of the con
Conan's show and that was with we were
even more ballsy with that because it
was 12:30 we were replacing David
Letterman and I was all about we're not
going to do anything Letterman's ever
done we're g to change this up because
it was like my dream that's still the
most exciting job I've ever had the late
night running a late night show yeah
because I mean David Letterman was our
hero I mean you know and and the the
opportunity to create a new version was
just an absolute thrill and we tried
everything crazy and you know a lot
of the comedy was working Conan was very
nervous and and kind of you know he he
wasn't a seasoned performer at that that
was the thing you know I I thought that
the trouble at the beginning when it was
like if it was so iffy it was more about
his performance the content thought that
made him so likable though I remember
that I remember loving him because
because I felt like he was so real and
yeah and you know I watched some of
these early shows and he's so charmingly
scared unassuming yeah yeah and I think
there was an audience that agreed with
you but like adults critics maybe were
like he sucks he's too scared he's not
but I remember when it started he was my
favorite but it was also it was also
that the the network wasn't sure like
the network would put you on but they
really didn't support in in we had
Lauren Michaels again if we didn't have
Lauren Les who made this incredibly bold
choice to let Conan have a shot at this
right you know and if we didn't have
Lauren we would have been off the air
for sure how long did you stay at at
Conan I only stayed for like a year and
a half because I got burned out because
I I like it was so thrilling to create
the show but then like as headwriter
first of all you don't have a lot of
time to write you're managing all this
other material and second of all you've
created all these incredibly exciting
bits you know whatever it was in the
year 2000 and actual items and the
staring contest you know we created this
Collective um you know body of work that
but then you have to just like okay um
what haven't we done in a couple of
weeks okay time to do another staring
contest it just becomes like refillable
so did you walk away I did walk away for
a couple of reasons I for that like it
was starting to feel creatively un
fulfilling but also I was a newlywed and
I had spent like eight years at Saturday
Night Live with the same
girlfriend and just I'd always put the
show first you know and even when I was
living with her and then like it
coincided the first year of Conan
coincided with me getting married and
once I was married it just felt like I I
just can't do this I can't be a husband
like this it sucked I I would still the
job was so grueling and I would come
home like at midnight every night and
that was just I just felt like I don't
want to I don't want this to be my
marriage you know it's one thing when
but you walked away from something that
is yeah absolutely huge as that kid who
went on that amateur show at NYU to
think that you were going to be the
spearhead of a network late night show
and then to make that choice it was it
was the greatest job I've ever had it
was an incredible thrill and
blast